I keep seeing these red flags everywhere
with Brian and yeah it's just it's just
I think just the hard ice on on Rachel
are kind of blinding her a little bit
Dean told us that Brian raises red flags
for him would you agree with that is
Brian raise some red flags for you no
I'm one of the guys that understands
Brian 2037 today I'm 36 Hey
well what I guess what I'm trying to say
by that is Brian all the conversations
I've had with Brian is just a guy who's
who's been there done it Brian's a great
looking dude is that a great career and
he's been there done that he's been he's
seen the game and now he's ready to find
his plane so that's all I ever got from
Brian was that he was ready to find his
queen so is Brian misunderstood because
some of the fans are skeptical of him I
feel like everybody's hating me you know
like yeah he's a good-looking dude he's
a chiropractor he's 37 but that doesn't
necessarily mean that he's promiscuous
or loose maybe he's just extremely picky
I myself am extremely picky so I get
Brian and I think I don't think he's
disingenuous I think Brian's the real
deal
[Music]